you can't even easily speak to a manager
at FedEx Kinkos
you gotta wait you gotta wait to think
going into the Vatican you can talk to
anybody
[Music]
a disgruntled tourist smashed two 2 000
year old statues busts
bus they were ugly huh in the Vatican
because he was denied a meeting with
Pope Francis I think that's fine if it's
at the Catholic church I think it's fine
anywhere else but the Vatican is a
beautiful thing oh for sure you've been
there right I bet it's beautiful
the Vatican in there man you feel like
you're in heaven already it's like just
the way it's built and like they got
these [ __ ] Windows where the sun
beams come in and you walk in here
the [ __ ] dude walking around with the
insets and [ __ ] you're just that side
wow like [ __ ] 50 feet with a ceiling
you know and you got marble floors that
looks like this and then you guys
and you got these kind of uh statues
it's [ __ ] Majestic in there man you
feel like you need to be on your best
behavior so you'd be pretty pissed at
someone that busted up two statues I'm
not even Catholic and when I go in there
I go dude [ __ ] respect but you know
how many people got um
you know what I'm talking about there oh
yeah I don't know how they could even do
it but he wasn't even fighting for that
yeah because I was thinking about that
he was being a brat yeah yeah yeah
that's true he was being a brat yeah
what if he was fighting for that what if
he was fighting against
yeah and that's why he wanted to talk to
him but that's how you fight for it well
bye to start is
it what do you do now you really needed
to go like confront the man that's how
they fought that's how they fought when
they didn't like Robert E Lee statues
what if it was an accident my uncle what
if he like slipped and bumped and hit
both it wasn't an accident it's because
the Marvel no those things are heavy man
you got to push those things over and
there's two of them yeah they smashed
two of them he like leaned on it was
like Oh and it slipped and hit like dude
basically would go you did 4 000 years
worth of damage
yeah
you have you know a sizeable following
on social media and all kinds of stuff
why when you were at the Vatican didn't
you walk up to uh the vatican's
cherimonte museum
and say like I'd like to speak to the
pope please I did not that was an option
oh this guy was just a walk-in and he
just like straight up demanded to see
him he just walked in bro he's a [ __ ]
tourist he he walks in he's visiting the
chairman Museum and he's like pulls a
guy outside he's like
yes I'd like to speak with the Pope
please and then they're like uh yeah no
and then he's like oh really huh and
then he starts [ __ ] up this ancient
you can't even easily speak to a manager
at FedEx Kinkos
you gotta wait you gotta watch him think
going into the Vatican you can talk to
anybody the inside is probably one of
the most beautiful plays I've ever been
in well it better be for how much we
[ __ ] give the collection dish
it's pretty epic and nuts in there I'm I
was really Catholic it was [ __ ] wild
how much money do you think you've given
the Catholic Church
my family
wild how much what do you think Wild
[ __ ] all right oh how much money is
there in the [ __ ] Federal Reserve
you know watching my grandma and my mom
and like it's like what the [ __ ] are you
guys doing like and and like I'm like
when I was a kid like getting groceries
was a big deal with four kids so oh yeah
wild yeah yeah but then like seeing my
mom just dropping [ __ ] cash money and
like during that when they pass the
trade around yeah was it just the
trailer were they doing that thing where
like 10 of your salary or some [ __ ] like
automatically the tithes no we didn't do
that oh yeah the tide no no it was just
like a sweepstakes amount yeah it was a
sweepstakes [ __ ] dude well I mean rather
than spend the money on groceries why
not spend the money for Jesus to feed
the children apparently but a phone I
think I know what he was feeding him he
was feeding them yeah yeah I was waiting
for somebody to do it is that he root
for barley I was pointing to Anthony and
he didn't even do it thank you listen JK
glossary we can't say certain words or
else the YouTube thing messes with us so
instead of saying things like grape we
say
yeah
starting today it's a little bit nicer
than you know what I mean yeah yeah
because that means like that sounds like
I did it fast it sounds like you like it
yeah I just got it done that you liked
it yeah that sounds more consensual yeah
whereas it sounds slower more methodical
yeah yeah yeah yeah that's what Bart's
getting at
JK glossary so what what is like a
punishment for a person who goes in and
like destroys like four thousand years
it has to be the new Statue they gotta
[ __ ] dip the dude in wax and is it
the Vatican City it's its own country
right so they probably have their own
rules they could probably lock his ass
they could probably assassinate his ass
so he wasn't turned over to the Vatican
police which would have been sick he was
turned over to the vet to the um the
Italian police the town please Italian
please oh that's Italian
it's just gonna get pizza and stuff
um no one knows what the tourists wanted
to talk with the Pope about they didn't
ask but and I think this is a little bit
sad state of our of our world
many people have questioned his mental
health oh God that has nothing to do
with it
okay no nothing to do just don't suppose
that kind of [ __ ] that's [ __ ] up what
if you like woke up one day or like he
got like a message from God and he's
like I have to go [ __ ] speak to the
pope because like you know that [ __ ]
used to happen it doesn't happen anymore
because you know there's like order and
structure in religion now but back then
cynicism right back to the people used
to just get [ __ ] messages from God I
could get a vision and then need to
report it but if you get it now you're
called a [ __ ] nut house yeah yeah
what if people are getting Visions from
God now and then God's like man dude
everyone's so [ __ ] goddamn picking
the wrong dude
yeah who do you if you get a vision from
God who do you talk to about that's what
I'm saying don't you like wouldn't you
be like [ __ ] I need to go see the Pope I
need to see the highest level well let's
just start with the regular [ __ ]
priests that you don't have to go
straight to the because like you got
your mayor right you go you got your
Senator whatever the chain of command
yeah you don't go straight to the
president sometimes you got to go
straight to the source if you got a
message from God that's already higher
up that's already above the mayor's pay
grade you know what I'm saying like what
if it's some serious I think I would be
a little bit more strategic than to put
a message with that person you think
he's tripping for putting two giant
monuments that are breakable right in
front of everybody you know what I mean
does that mean the Vatican needs to do
[ __ ] uh mental health checks before
they just let people walk in with a
coven Q-tip we might be there have you
guys heard about the the kids who talk
who say that they saw Mary Magdalene
like they they say that she in the flesh
them they all know they all have the
same dream they all like sleeping oh the
same [ __ ] dream like they were all
sleeping in different places around the
world at the same time no it's in the
same place in Portugal whoa okay which
is a very lovely place to visit it was
Apparition Lisbon is very nice I mean I
think that'd be impressive if none of
them have ever heard of Mary Magdalene
so they had they had but
um so is all like the same in the same
Village right
they they're tending to a flock of sheep
outside this Village tending to sheep is
like right in that biblical yeah it
feels good all right Jason they saw an
angel the angel was transparent and it
was shining like a crystal
and then they say their names are Lucia
jacinta and Francisco and they were like
nine years old six years old and seven
years old they were stunned and then the
angel says don't be afraid I'm an angel
peace pray with me and then the angel
said that
um the said that you know there's
there's going to be Visions coming to
you and they started seeing for the
Virgin Mary
as a lady dressed in white shining
brighter than the sun giving out rays of
clear and intense light she promised to
come to the children on the 13th of each
month and then dude all this [ __ ] the
Vatican has like in their texts what the
kids were told from Mary like the Mary
told them like three predictions about
like the world or some [ __ ] and like all
three of them got inscribed and
transcoded into like the Vatican
archives and planted there like the
first two the Vatican released or like
the world released them the third one
they didn't release it but then they
released it like [ __ ] in 2008 it's
like 12 or some [ __ ] but they didn't the
people think that they [ __ ] up oh they
that they lied about what Mary said in
the third really yeah but we're the
first two right it's big
that's kind of interesting what's the uh
is there any more information like
beyond that like is it would is there
something about 9 11 but
but it was like a two years too late
yeah it was like no it was early it was
like kind of big
it's like yeah like something will
happen in New York New York and like
an extra Liberty like they're gonna get
hit with planes they didn't say what
type of planes
see that's what's cool I like people who
have visions of [ __ ] they didn't that
don't all really exist like that's dope
right or or do something impressive like
tell the [ __ ] deal or no deal
contestant which suitcase has the
[ __ ] oh my God something that's
easily but I like it when the white
ladies wake up and they speak Chinese
all of a sudden that's pretty cool bro
when I was in [ __ ] Prayer Warriors
and I was like prayer Warrior yeah I
would do like weekly meets with people
who had gifts of God so they would like
do this like one of them it's like
[ __ ] X-Men like wannabes and then
they'll just like one lady had the power
of like she would close her eyes then
you put a pencil in her hand and a paper
and then she would just write what God's
saying and she was just like frantically
writing and it was like cursive [ __ ] and
then she would read it out to the group
and it would be like thine is thy thee
thy thou like all those types of
vernacular yeah well it's not like
literal the vernacular yeah so she
writes like that and every and uh one
other girl goes God still talk like that
you think he'd update his uh his wording
you know
it was really funny so
that's [ __ ] good started to fall
apart at that point for me
[Music]